we are learning these stunning new
details about the FBI's investigation
into president Trump according to the
New York Times the FBI was so concerned
when President Trump fired former
director James Comey that it launched a
counterintelligence investigation to
look into whether mr. Trump was secretly
working for Russia
Errol Barnett is at the White House with
more air all good morning good morning
look we've known that former FBI
director James Comey z' firing and
president Trump's dismissal of him has
been a focus of the special counsels
probe and whether or not that is an
obstruction of justice but the New York
Times spoke with former investigation
officials and those familiar with the
matter who say they also weighed whether
the president's actions undermined
national security shortly after
President Trump fired his then FBI
director James Comey in May 2017 law
enforcement officials reportedly began
investigating whether the president was
working on behalf of Russia New York
Times reports that FBI officials
launched an inquiry after the president
connected commis dismissal to the Russia
investigation on two occasions I was
going to fire call me I there's no good
time to do it once in this NBC interview
in which President Trump appeared to say
he dismissed Comey
because of the Russia probe and in fact
when I decided to just do it I said to
myself I said you know this Russia thing
with Trump and Russia is a made-up story
it's an excuse by the Democrats for
having lost an election that they should
have won and the other instance that
reportedly alarmed investigators was a
letter mr. Trump wrote to Comey in which
he thanked the outgoing FBI director for
telling him he was not a subject of the
FBI's Russia probe there was no
coalition president Trump has vehemently
denied any wrongful connection to Moscow
and so far there has been no evidence
made public that mr. Trump was in secret
contact or took direction from Russian
officials press secretary Sarah Sanders
fired back against the report writing in
a statement quote this is absurd James
Comey was fired because he's a disgraced
partisan hack president Trump has
actually been tough on Russia now the
counterintelligence probe was wrapped in
- the overall Russia investigation but
it is unclear if special counsel mullah
is still pursuing that angle of it now
investigators also reportedly considered
Oprah opening this aspect of the
investigation during the 2016 election
but were unsure of how to proceed of
something with such a high magnitude of
importance Michelle
sounds like a lot still left to unravel
Errol Barnett in Washington thank you so
much